[MUSIC PLAYING]
ARHAAN SAKSENA: Hi.
Arhaan here.
I'm an enterprise customer
engineer at Google Cloud.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And
hi from me, Priyanka.
I'm a customer engineer, and
I help Google Cloud customers
understand their big data.
On an episode earlier,
we looked at managing
containerized applications
with Kubernetes engine.
And you had the chance to
deploy a containerized app
in Qwiklabs.
You can check out the
link to that episode here.
ARHAAN SAKSENA: On
this episode, we're
taking it to another level.
Through a hands-on
lab, you're going
to learn how to build a
Slack bot using Botkit.
And then run it on
Kubernetes engine.
You'll also interact with the
bot in a live Slack channel.
[WHOOSH]
OK.
So a quick recap on
Kubernetes engine.
Containers address
the problem of how
to easily and
consistently deploy apps
in different
environments by allowing
them to be broken into
smaller, independent pieces.
These can then be deployed
and managed dynamically.
Containerization also
allows the separation
of apps from infrastructure.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Leveraging
Google's infrastructure,
Kubernetes engine provides the
perfect managed environment
for deploying,
managing, and scaling
your containerized applications.
By simply describing
the compute, memory,
and storage resources your
apps containers require,
Kubernetes engine automatically
provisions and manages
the underlying cloud resources.
ARHAAN SAKSENA: In this
lab, creating a cluster
on Kubernetes engine will
ensure that it adds a new node
to your cluster if your pods
don't have enough capacity
to run.
Conversely, if a node in your
cluster is underutilized,
Kubernetes engine
can delete the node.
You'll also use Kubernetes
engine to create a deployment.
[WHOOSH]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Bot
users enable workspaces
to interact with external
services or your custom code,
and have many of
the same qualities
as their human counterparts.
Bot users have profiles
photos and names.
They can be direct
messaged or mentioned.
They can post messages
and upload files.
And they can even be
invited to and kicked out
of a public and
private conversation.
ARHAAN SAKSENA: The
biggest difference
between bots and
regular users is
that, instead of interacting
with the workspace
through mobile or desktop
apps, bots are controlled
programmatically through APIs.
Within a Slack channel,
bots can do nearly anything
you program them to do.
[WHOOSH]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right.
Time for Qwiklabs.
In this hands-on
lab, you are going
to create a bot that
posts a simple message.
ARHAAN SAKSENA: By
completing the lab,
you're going to learn how
to create a custom bot
integration in Slack, build
a node.js image in Docker,
upload a Docker image to
a private Google Container
Registry, and run a Slack
bot on Kubernetes engine.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: You
can check out the links
to start the Qwiklabs here.
Keep in mind that
it's going to take you
about an hour to complete.
ARHAAN SAKSENA: The lab
requires access to a Slack team
where you're authorized to
create custom integrations.
To set up the lab, you clone
the code repository and install
node.js dependencies.
We then create a new Slack app,
add a new bot user to the app,
and get the bot user
an OAuth access token.
We edit the node.js file
with the OAuth access token.
We run the bot.
In Slack, we can see that
our bot user is now online.
We send our bot a message,
and get a response.
We hope you enjoyed
this episode.
If you've developed
other cool Slack bots,
we'd love to hear about them.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: If
you haven't signed up
for the $300 free trial credit
on GCP, check out this link.
It's a great way to apply
what you've learned.
ARHAAN SAKSENA: All of our
additional training resources
are linked below.
Thanks again for watching,
and see you soon.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Want to know
more about Deployment Manager?
Check out our full episode
where we dive into a lab
and highlight this service.
[MUSIC PLAYING]